When you think of an image,
you kind of dream it up first.
[CAMERA SHUTTER]
[AMBIENT MUSIC]
There is no difference
in how I approach
making an assignment
like a "Vogue" cover
or a personal shoot.
I fixate on an idea.
Then, I go out and
make my idea happen.
In this class, I'm
going to be discussing
what I do when I make portraits
of subjects in natural light.
I'll be walking
through how I compose
my photos and essentially
all the ingredients that
go into the recipe
of making pictures.
For my early work,
the camera that I used,
was a camera that I
borrowed from my friend.
You don't need expensive gear
to make beautiful photography.
Whatever you can
get your hands on,
I would suggest to
try, even your phone.
With what you have
in your pocket,
it is very possible to
make something striking
and to tell a story.
Gorgeous.
It's important to be adaptable
to whatever kind of sunlight
conditions you get and to work
with it and not against it.
That's nice.
With film, it's a
very patient process.
You're not trying to just
like shoot, shoot, shoot.
That's nice there.
Hold that.
[CAMERA SHUTTER]
To tell your own stories,
it's important to think
about your experiences
in your life.
I mainly want to see
protagonists both look like me
and be experiencing a certain
freedom in public space.
So when I make images of
friends hula hooping or enjoying
seemingly mundane
pleasures, it's
about thinking
about freedom that I
wish for them and for myself.
The most important thing to do
is to continue making pictures
and to share them online.
That's been the main
way through which people
have been able to engage with
my work to see what I'm up to.
There are no rules to this.
OK.
Suppress those
feelings of self-doubt.
That's perfect.
The main thing that
you should follow
is what excites you,
what inspires you,
and your personal sensibilities.
Now, ask yourself what kind
of stories do I want to tell?
I'm Tyler Mitchell, and
this is my MasterClass.